Germany's oldest wine producing region
is located near the Mosel River and it's
tributaries the landscape and climate
were deciding factors for the Romans who
set up vineyards here the steep slopes
not only store heat which is good for
the grace they also add a very special
flavour to the local wines Riesling is a
good example the slate has a different
composition wherever it is the
particular slate here gives the wine its
character
there are hundreds and thousands of
different compositions of the slate the
Mosel Valley is now famous worldwide for
producing fine wines that wasn't just
wine that the Romans brought to Germany
the Western Roman Emperor lived in Trier
visible to this day with the porta [ __ ]
or Black Gate the Basilica the
amphitheater and the Imperial baths
we now move from the oldest winemaking
area in Germany to one of the biggest in
the false region the area around
Neustadt on the vine Strasser is home to
about 3600 winemakers who produce a
quarter of Germany's wines the most
prominent of Riesling and Mullah to gow
the wine route running through the area
is one of the oldest tourist trails in
Germany it's hiking and cycling paths
also take visitors to destinations where
they can sample the hearty delights of
local cooking and these days that
includes internationally acclaimed
restaurants such as here in died as home
we have a lot of good restaurants in the
region it's worth coming here for the
food to locals used to drive over to
France to eat now people from Alsace
come here los Hambach was witness to a
groundbreaking moment in German history
it was here that the black red and gold
colours of the modern flag were first
flown in public in 1832 the old castle
ruins played host to a huge rally
demanding greater civil rights it's
considered the cradle of German
democracy we now head east to another
historical region steeped in winemaking
culture northern Bavaria they've been
making wine here since the 8th century
but some of the vintners like to present
a modern image mullet ogre and Silvana
grapes are especially popular in these
parts the evolution in image is
reflected in the labeling a good example
is on the flattened bottle typical for
Franconian wines
many winemaking businesses have now
opened modern upscale wine stores as
well in some cases they are the product
of special architecture competitions but
the colloquium was a wine tasting
session we just introduced our wines to
the architects the architects tried to
translate the expression of that
language of wine into architecture the
building you can see there was the
winner vena birdsburg is an example of
how Germany's Vinny cultura has evolved
since Roman times today the country is
one of Europe's big four wine producers
together with France Italy and Spain one
thing has remained the same over the
years however the local appreciation and
celebration of a good glass of wine